j'accueille jean gaudreault
[Musique]
elle
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
jean claude drouot en banlieue
parisienne la terre que thierry la
fronde foule aujourd'hui est celle de
son jardin potager qu'il entretient
quotidiennement
je passe les journées une journée
entière depuis après le petit déjeuner
je reviens
déjeuner
quand la terre se valent à ces miettes
comme ça aussi
proche de la nature jean-claude le
jardinier met un point d'honneur à
cultiver bio évidemment que je cultive
veut
sans engrais sans pesticides et je fais
des composts
tous ces produits sont ne sont pas
[Applaudissements]
sont pas poussés dans le verger l'homme
est connaisseur en raisins qui
est un peu bizarre
parce qu'il
[Applaudissements]
il mûrit très inégalement alors jeune
kate à la grave
j'invite
les uns et les autres à faire vraiment
le apprendre détruit le plus mûr
ramener
petit cadeau pour ma femme
bien tu veux porter un moment à l'orée
du jardin nous retrouverons son suisse
renoue
là ça va oui alors tout va bien bon je
les ai récolté ce matin ils sont parce
qu'il faut pas tourner ici à l'humilité
parce qu'après ne commença à courir et
jean-claude nous invite dans la demeure
étonnante qu'il occupe depuis qu'il a
tenu le rôle de thierry la fronde alors
ici c'est une
ancienne ferme mais où 19e et ça a été
transformé cette verrière c'était un
artiste peintre qui
voit là une densité de l'atelier alors
ici ben voilà c'est mon atelier aussi
qu' étant là en pleine bourrasque de
création voilà ça ça va après demain je
pars je vais
donner un
travail que j'ai que j'ai fait sur jean
de la fontaine homme libre et libertin
la fontaine nous donne une sort une
jouissance d'une délicatesse d'une
subtilité
magnifique merveilleuse c'est délicieux
c'est un c'est de la musique pure et
ancien pensionnaire de la comédie
française a pour projet de jouer en
compagnie de renaud la pièce qu'il a
écrite mozart père et fils le père qui
écrivait le plus puis à l'époque c'était
pas des sms un jeu dire que donc quand
on écrivait on écrivait vraiment
alors ces lettres dit il les connaît par
coeur ce qu'il a écrit il connaît par
coeur il les a tellement lu et relu
voilà c'est ça le principe c'est
vraiment mozart père et fils et drew
père et fils
c'est ce et est 7 e binôme est géré ses
rapports sur les mêmes louis gros je me
fais engueuler pendant vidéo et demi
ça c'est du bois de mon fils pour
jean-claude l'heure est à la pause
sieste c'est pas de longues siestes et
c'est une
c'est le moment
de la frontière trk prêt
mentalement je vais je je me dirige vers
la représentation du soir
en
route pour de nouvelles aventures
sa nouvelle aventure c'est la mise en
scène de la pièce le visiteur d'eric
emmanuel schmitt dans laquelle joue
francis lalanne
trop bien trop bien
toute sa vie là il l'a concentrer sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire sur sa passion
monsieur sur le théâtre passion qui
l'animé
qui l'a toujours animé je pense que
toute sa vie il allait il a été fidèle à
cette passion
tu suives francis on se rejoint là
cinquante ans plus tard thierry la
fronde est bien loin jean claude roux
est tout entier dévoué à la noblesse du
théâtre
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
jean claude drouot jean-claude bienvenue
sur plateau de tout le monde à part et
merci à vous n'êtes ni le 17 décembre
1938 à lessines en belgique père wallon
mère flamande mais vous dites je ne
choisis pas entre les deux communautés
elles forment notre pays c'est un vrai
bien belge profond voilà et définitif je
n'ai jamais souhaité demander ma
naturalisation
qui pouvait sembler évidente le
tempérament profond je crois qu'ils les
flamands chez moi alors votre famille
dans la minoterie un oui les drouot
prospère dans la farine famille aisée de
bonne bourgeoisie
mon grand père disait on descend du
général drouot c'était une fierté bon en
fait de général drew antoine roux qui
est une très belle figure magnifique
lesage la grande armée m'ont appelé
n'a pas eu d'enfants difficile de
descendre de geeks qui n'a pas mais par
contre la yole
vérifier la gueule direct c'est le frère
du père du général de gaulle alors
enfance et adolescence sans histoire
vous fait vos études à l'athénée date et
à 18 ans vous retrouvez à l'université
libre de bruxelles où vous entendez
suivre en même temps des cours de droit
et de médecine pour ibiza certaines
ambitions quand même oui non non c'est
pas d'ambition c'est de l'inconscience
mais tout ça parce que
c'était pour faire plaisir à maman et
puis le droit mais c'était oui j'étais
j'avais fait une un tournoi gagné un
tournoi d'éloquence avec pour thème la
délinquance juvénile alors je vais lui
l'envi d'être juge pour enfants oui
voilà et puis et puis j'ai vu j'ai vu
le tnp jean vidal et voilà c'est l'école
des femmes non oui l'école des femmes
avec georges wilson qui a été mon
professeur dans la suite et ça a été le
déclic en fait à complet définitif et
finalité oui alors après une formation
aux jeunes théâtre de l'université libre
de belgique
vous entrez en 1959 au cours de charles
dullin à paris les professeurs c'était
ben c'est elle et les des acteurs du
tempo georges wilson halak unis jean
pierre darasse sauf un banc georges
leroy qui avait été le professeur au
conservatoire de jura philippe alors dès
1962 vous interprétez des tragédies
classiques des grandes oeuvres de
molière est là de 1963 à 1966 vous allez
devenir thierry dejean ville dit thierry
la fronde feuilleton à succès de rtf
créée par jean claude dray qui lui même
joue d'ailleurs dans la série messieurs
florent qui est le père de zabou
breitman qui joue isabelle oui zabuza
bouge méconnue elle avait deux ans une
bille était
alors l'histoire c'est thierry la fronde
qui s'est juré de délivrer le roi de
france jean le bon qui est prisonnier
des anglais c'est un peu robin et
c'était le robin des bois français à la
main comme ont identifié way terry
fichet la pâtée aux anglais c'est une
série que le général de gaulle adoré at
on dit à
quelqu'un un jour m'a même rapporté une
anecdote assez récemment disant rejeter
la voiture du général on était on avait
été bloquée devait aller probablement à
colombey les deux églises et et la
voiture était bloquée par une
manifestation paysanne et puis au bout
d'un intérêt général se tourner vers son
aide de camp ben il lui dit écoutez
vincent on va faire venir tirer
d'apprendre il va vous y
verrez ça vite fait bien fait ou me
rendais compte de de gaulle qu'il faut
faire venir tirer la fronde nicolas
sarkozy quand il supprime la publicité
sur france 2 qui dit ce qui était bien
c'est et thierry la fronde pas c'est
quand même incroyable il a bien marqué
l'histoire de la télévision comme ça
avec son danseur cause y avait de la
joie
à la visite sur le tournage on se
battaient en duel comme des gamins
n'hésitez pas un problème de passer de
deux racines de corneille de molière à
feuilleton télé pour vous
j'étais aux anges étaient en répétition
de cette pièce d'euripide nord-est et le
metteur en scène robert guez avait vu
500 600 jeunes comédiens pour distribuer
son personnage alors j'y vais moi aussi
l'envoyer par les cours d'informatique
et au bout de cinq minutes 15 me dit
vous êtes un archange déchu non alors je
dis ah bon très bien alors je lui dis
que je préparais de la pièce bon écoutez
si ça vous amuse demain je fais passer à
tel endroit c'était derrière les
organisent des essais si ça vous amuse
devenait bon j'y suis allé et ô surprise
je vois cette jeune apollon tous blonds
on ne peut plus blond aux yeux bleus
ou verts bon gt2 il a un petit canard
longtemps que je voyais la différence et
puis j'y suis allée comme dans mes jeux
d'enfants voilà bien sûr avec fougue
avec enthousiasme et ça a complètement
perturbé l'idée qu'ils avaient de leur
personnage et puis donc ils ont gardé le
meilleur à leurs yeux de 17 arc ange
blond aux yeux verts et moi on a refait
des essais et j'ai reçu un télégramme me
disant on espère ne pas se tromper mais
c'est vous qu'on choisit alors la bon
vous devenez une star effectivement je
me souviens c'était exceptionnel thierry
la fronde des c'était vraiment ri j'ai
connu ce que connaissait claude françois
tétreault au début au début c'est le
père noël un lait puis les premiers mois
c'est étonnant je dire on en a plein
plein les mirettes ce soit à l'époque en
plus ce n'est pas là la concurrence qui
aujourd'hui non il y avait une chaîne
voilà une star de la télé on évoque la
star oui alors quelles ont été les
réactions de votre votre entourage vos
parents par exemple aux mamans étaient
très fiers oui oui alors voyez ce qui
peut être un contrat riant j'avais une
une tante qui un jour je vais le rendre
visite
il avait un petit chien ridicule et puis
elle me dit je les appelais tirer
et avec les médias comment ça se passait
à l'époque
un collectionneur il ya pas longtemps
bas portés en un an ou un an et demi
j'ai eu 25 30 couvertures de magazines
donc c'est dire mais moi même j'étais
même pas conscients
ça me semblait normal même été assez
vite assez vite quand de business s'est
engouffré là dedans parce que c'était un
gros succès
ça ça ne m'a pas plu ouais vraiment vous
gagnez de l'argent avec cette saison non
non je viens à un serveur d'acteurs ses
troupes de jeunes acteurs mais j'aurais
pu j'aurais pu en gagner beaucoup on a
fait des propositions d aberrante sur le
plan amoureux
ça vous a apporté des conquêtes non oui
oui oui m'enfin je sens ans je n'ai pas
abusé non parce que pouvant par exemple
l'inscription maintenant oui oui il ya
prescription mais ce dont je suis
vraiment profondément le plus fier c'est
qu'avec clair ma femme nous en sommes à
51 ans de vie commune est en tout cas
ben c'est elle qui a un qui a résisté à
ce qui pouvait être une ou une fragilité
ou des tentations
parfois pas totalement réprimer des
choses comme ça quel était le meilleur
moment de cette époque j'emploie c'était
un grand jeu c'est un jeune en grand
lyon n'était c'est les combats dans la
forêt c'est ça qui vous restent comme le
meilleur souvenir vous voyez puis les
galopades de gazaouis ça oui et le pire
moment de l'époque
au bout de deux ans j'ai décidé de ne
pas continuer bah oui c'est ça oui voilà
et bien je peux vous dire qu'après le
vraiment cette avalanche de de renommée
d'intérêt médiatique et je disais bon
merci merci ça a été formidable je vais
avant je vais apprendre mon métier eh
bien il n'y a pas eu un jeu insiste pour
dire ab c'est bien ce garçon il veut
apprendre son métier on trouvait que
j'étais fou que je ne qu'après avec une
chance pareille qui arrive une fois tous
les vingt ans et elle commenté on n'a
pas le droit de cracher dans
dans le chaudron etc alors ensuite agnès
varda vous propose d'être la vedette de
son film le bonheur c'est pour moi une
fierté formidable c'est mon premier film
de cinéma et je me suis promis jeudi jeu
peut-être qu'il n'avait pas d'autres
mais en tout cas je vais être fidèle à
la à la qualité de ceux là et un jour
un an à près de la sortie
à l'olympia avec jeter voisin de jacques
brel et de marie laforêt et vos concerts
de sammy davis junior et en sortant brel
me dit j'ai vu le bonheur ça c'est bien
il y avait tellement de films après le
bonheur donc pas en france j'ai tourné
avec claude chabrol rupture william
klein j'ai tourné avec les avec tony
richardson
j'ai tourné avec richard burton j'ai des
anecdotes parfois épouvantables
en fait votre truc c'est théâtre quoi
c'est le sait le théâtre alors au
théâtre vous faites d'abord le cimetière
des voitures d'arrabal 167 grand moment
ensuite son jardin des délices en 69
mais enfin de faire son lit c'est eva
peron de copies est ce que vous êtes sur
scène au théâtre de l'épée de bois rue
de la montagne sainte geneviève quand
les péronistes vient d'attaquer le
théâtre à payer j'étais sur scène
ça a été un commando du péroniste vrais
seins et kiki taguées sur les murs perd
on perd on ne sera pas sali par un mois
j'étais très maquillée et puis je me
souviens c'est une
grande grande barre de fer
disant toi toi le [ __ ] et tire toi on
casse la gueule il avait commencé à
mettre le feu à un théâtre bien sûr
alors en 1984 vous êtes nommé à la tête
du centre dramatique de reims par jack
lang en 85 directeur du théâtre national
de belgique et vous revenez au
feuilleton télé avec des gros succès les
rois maudits dans lequel vous incarnez
gaston fébus les gens de mogador la
rivière espérance oui debout rendez vous
très beau j'étais vraiment capté très
régulièrement alors aujourd'hui est ce
que vous êtes nostalgique de cette
époque de thierry la fronde quand vous
étiez une énorme star non non non et je
sais très bien qu'aucun projet ne pourra
je le sais depuis longtemps ne pourra
jamais concurrencer avec le destin de ce
personnage
bon voilà c'est comme ça et ça m'a vite
simplement à essayer de donner de donner
le meilleur de moi même au jour le jour
et puis voilà si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil
j'aurais souhaité faire de meilleures
études secondaires
gtj devenant soudain ça s'est effondrée
ce m'intéressait plus probablement que
c'est la chrysalide comme ça vers un
ailleurs mais
j'ai jacky en énorme goût de la lecture
et la culture des anciens terrains et là
je vous dise sapristi vraiment si
j'avais pu là j'ai l'impression
maintenant d'avoir à rattraper les
années perdues
le jour vous allez mourir casual et
qu'on écrive sur votre tombe jean claude
à côté du moins à côté du moins le nom
de ma femme quand viendra à son tour
très beau merci merci très heureux de
rallumer la lumière soir où jean claude
martin merci à l'équipe pour être sûr de
ne rien rater le i know you tube abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu